well polo is back in town don't you know
get your pinky out
with the t the lamborghini las vegas
polo classic setting up right now
at the south point arena hector mejia is
live this morning with details oh my
goodness hector we're going to try it
again we're going to try the horse again
i have a good vibe about this time
though
you know what and i so do i have a great
vibe too this is laila we uh traded
horses this is a new one and this is a
more of a calm horse compared to the one
previously but i want to say it's kind
of my fault because i just
jumped right on susie q earlier
literally 10 seconds before our live
shot and susan q was a little uneasy
uh but you know it was let's just say
yeah it was my fault but joining us live
here
we have tony good morning good morning
so tell us about
the game of the match that's coming up
and you know for those who will be
attending
what do we look out for you know
obviously we look at the ball but you
know what do we look out for
so basically this sport is played three
and three in the arena
so you're gonna have six players and two
umpires watching the six players
to make sure they don't foul so six six
total horses and
total horses because the umpires are on
horses too
so basically you want to look for number
three the number three is the captain
i'm wearing the number three jersey here
by the way for the record i'm the
captain here
number one is a forward so you want to
watch at the number
one usually he's the one that he or she
is going to make the goal
and number two is a runner and the
defense
the sport is really fast in the arena
and very close
proximity as fast as a lamborghini
absolutely these horses they go at full
speed
and uh just like my favorite car
lamborghini
i used to own one i still in the market
to buy one
anyway there's actually one outside we
can actually test drive right
there we go yes there is there is a
guyardo outside to test drive
so i get to take it home too the sport
has got a lot of excitement basically
you're playing soccer and
horse so a lot of activity uh
it's it's as good as it gets so you have
to hold the reins you also
have to hold the mallet you also have to
worry about your posture
and start so this is what is played
almost
75 80 percent of time off the saddle and
so you be mobile
and be able to like this so you're
holding the mallet you're holding the
rain
you're running up up and down and you
have other
players trying to kill you off awesome
well thank
you so much thank you for your time uh
so yeah like we were just saying there's
a lamborghini outside we might test
drive we'll
have that update it's an update still
ahead in 30 minutes for now reporting
live from the south point arena hector
mejia
8 news now back to you guys